we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p so let me
explain this because this was something
from the bonus show yesterday on the
bonus show yesterday we discussed
because of some prisoners in tennessee
opting for the electric chair over
lethal injection because of some of the
botched the lethal injections that there
have been Pat and I discussed on
yesterday's bonus show what would we
choose if we were on death row the
Eggman called in with a different
question about if we were on death row
take a listen to this hey it's
interesting discussing what way you
would want to be put to death but more
interesting would be discussing what you
would choose for your last meal Pat
would you go out vegan Shalom brothers
right well listen um with the
possibility that I would end up getting
clemency or that it just wouldn't work
to put me to death I would probably go
very healthy I'd have like some steamed
chicken with no skin and maybe some
broccoli sauteed with just a little bit
of soy sauce I mean I would it's so
unclear Pat at this point if when you're
scheduled to be executed you actually
will be that I would stick with
something healthy and in case I end up
living yeah I think I would still treat
it like it was my last meal and that's
why I would order one of everything from
veggie galaxy here in Cambridge
Massachusetts I would get the chicken
and waffles
I absolutely would get the seitan cutlet
of the week and you better believe I'm
gonna get the side of mac and cheese to
go along with it so what you're saying
is but by the way what kind of cheese
are they using in that V please tell me
it's not that cashew cheese I get is
cashew cheese I don't know here that
many alternatives cowboy so even if it
was your last meal you wouldn't say you
know what I want that taste of that
sweet real chicken one more time before
I die you wouldn't do that well I do
love the premise that apparently I'm
still vegan but I'm also committing
crimes that are so heinous that they're
worthy of the death penalty like I'm a
vegan serial killer or something but no
I don't think I would break vegan I
think I would stick with it to the end
the bitter end all right you've heard it
you heard it from Pat and I might also
have some okra why not right I mean it's
my last meal I might go crazy we've got
a great bonus show for you today we will
talk about this horrible story about a
missionary who was killed on a remote
Indian island and now the the retrieval
of his remains is increasingly
problematic I think that they should
just forget about it this is how we got
into this problem in the first place we
will also talk about migrants attempting
to cross the English Channel from France
in canoes and is it dinghies or din jeez
its Bing Bing I never know how to say
that those little thingies okay I grew
up on a lake and now we are yeah I think
it is thinking yeah dingy is something
else we'll talk about that later and
we'll also talk about global outrage
about Chinese researchers claiming that
they have produced the first Jean edited
babies and the a higher up at CRISPR has
issued a statement about this all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show how do you get the bonus show two
ways be a member or be a patron for at
least five bucks a month membership
ww join pakman.com patreon patreon.com
slash david pakman show